hey what's going on is filburn it's time
for the Monday morning podcast for a
Monday [ __ ] March 12th March 12th a
very important day of the history of
March that was the day that was the
first stage /of it wore a top hat on
stage or was it Abraham Lincoln would
you say that those the most famous
people who ever wore a top hat right now
did Lincoln just get shot while he was
wearing one so that's how everybody
always draws him I don't know I feel
like you got to be a certain height
that's that's tall people [ __ ] you know
to have a [ __ ] top hat and tails you
know is there anything funnier than
seeing somebody short wearing tall
people [ __ ] you know like when you went
to your prom that [ __ ] little [ __ ]
five foot six inch fireplug showing up
wearing the [ __ ] tails looking like a
little goddamn penguin do people even
wear tails that even have proms anymore
is it considered unsafe I know that
they're supervised and that they started
to [ __ ] booked comedians at them and
now who's kidding who I guess they
always should have been
especially if you have a daughter
speaking of ladies and ladies ladies get
in for free they never talk about that
when they talk about equal pay huh
ladies night leave your money at home
and bring your snatch cuz you're not
paying for [ __ ] right they don't talk
about that do they all the nightclubs
they get in for free for free actually
what they really mean don't they really
mean beautiful women beautiful women get
in for free you know
mediocre to ugly women then they just
start going like hey you know where uh
what kind of full right now and what
does that do that causes of movement I
went to a club the other night they said
it was full and it wasn't
you know I know that because all of a
sudden these other women who yeah they
were skinnier
yeah they had better bone structure yeah
they were better-looking and they
wouldn't let me in they let them in guys
right one of people who aren't
good-looking just go to admit that
they're not good-looking and just
realize that they're gonna have to walk
through another door in life it makes
you stronger you know I'd love to have
sympathy for you but I'm a bald
redheaded male so I mean you [ __ ]
preaching to the choir
you know you think the club wasn't full
when I showed up make me my own room
this is the [ __ ] poor me era of human
beings as we ignore real real real [ __ ]
real [ __ ] that's going on what kind of
real [ __ ] is going on bill I know
there's got to be something more
important than [ __ ] bathrooms right
already got bathrooms pick one sorry
anyways
plowing ahead here yeah you're probably
wondering why I'm in such a weird
fucked-up mood I'm really not in a
whiffle I'm in a good mood this is me in
a good mood I cleaned up my office
finally finally put things in their
proper place found a lot of [ __ ] that I
thought I lost or misplaced or even
forgot that I even had now I'm
minimalist we'll be like well that's
that's what you need to get you need to
get rid of all this you need to get rid
of those where does it go they're
minimalist into the ocean into a [ __ ]
dump okay stop acting like every [ __ ]
post-it you have out there you're gonna
go sell on Craigslist and someone's
gonna want to buy it okay isn't it more
environmentally sound to be a hoarder
rather than sending all your [ __ ] to the
dump poisoning the soil you have it
contained within your own apartment or
house
or Cabana or guesthouse depending on
your living situation you can't tell me
ever since Oh Jay that when you're in a
guest house you can't you can't be the
guest and think what if the [ __ ]
person who owns this kills their spouse
and somebody else who happen to be there
wait am I gonna be the person who
happens to be there
all right note to self the entire time
I'm a guest in this guy's house just
make sure I'm always where I'm supposed
to be how will I know where I'm supposed
to be I'm just gonna avoid this [ __ ]
guy and pay the rent on time that's what
Oh Jay did a lot of people talk about
the bad that he did okay which is pretty
obvious at this point but the good that
he did is I think the behavior of people
in guest houses I bet if you were able
to chart it if you got an algorithm or
whatever is these number cruncher
crunching people do they would find that
the behavior of the kato kaelin of the
world dramatically improved after Oh
Jake you know well I guess you can't say
killed those two people he was acquitted
it's [ __ ] up how the [ __ ] you supposed
to say that I you know I don't I think I
just talked myself into a corner look at
the bird that [ __ ] bird out there you
know a lot you know I'm just sitting
there looking at that [ __ ] thing how
that fat [ __ ] that bird just flew the
way it just did I think it's all about
the legs I think yeah you know I bet if
you got a [ __ ] really skinny person
right had a beer belly and they had
little bird legs no I still wouldn't
work with it you know what I bet you
could get him to try if you talk to him
long enough if you talk to him long
enough you know come on look at you
shaped just like a bird and you're
smarter than that [ __ ] thing give it
a jump come on sorry anyways this is
Sunday afternoon I just put
absolutely darling daughter in the other
room for a nap so I got the [ __ ] Big
Brother camera going here where the [ __ ]
is it [ __ ] with a [ __ ] the camera god
dammit I just [ __ ] had this thing I
was killing it I had everything going
the way I needed to be going oh there it
is there it is what is she doing oh
she's sleeping
Rockabye cutie in the other room
something something and I'll get up room
clean up all the [ __ ] that fell on the
floor and then you'll come out and do it
some more
Oh dad can you stop singing your nerd
songs anyways you know it's [ __ ]
amazing is I'm getting my Invisalign off
just like oj allegedly I'm getting my
Invisalign off this Wednesday I can't
[ __ ] wait I'm on tray number 13 it
was projected to take 16 weeks but I had
these [ __ ] in the whole time I did my
half of my stand-up sets I left them and
spitting all over the [ __ ] stage I
just wanted to get it over with
right that's a big thing in life when
they would something sucks just get it
over with okay you get tossed overboard
in the ocean you know what I mean you
see that shark fin don't swim away from
it you swim at it headfirst get it over
with
anyways I'm getting my Invisalign off
and then they give me a mouth guard so
for the rest of my life when I go to
sleep I just pop in the mouth guard and
then I'm fine
and the [ __ ] will stay the same and and
it's also cool cuz you know occasionally
I will grind my teeth at night because
I'm a lunatic or I'm stressed I don't
know what it is but it's something I've
done ever since I was a little kid so
anyway so it all worked out it all [ __ ]
worked out and I highly recommend it and
they're not paying me to tell you guys
that [ __ ] Invisalign is too [ __ ] but
it's the [ __ ]
you know considering what they used to
do put all that barbed wire in your
[ __ ] mouth you know then god forbid
you got into a fight it was just like
you were a [ __ ] bleed
well someone I do is just punch you
right in the mouth I won't claim we were
playing kill the man with not kill the
man with the ball that's what we used to
call that game you just pick up the
football and start running and although
you half your grade would tackle you and
then you just coughed it up and someone
else got it it was [ __ ] great we
played at all
we played it every day outdoor recess
just about you come in you wouldn't you
weren't even sore your body was
brand-new
he had a big puffy coat on that's all
you needed
so we were playing football one time and
I was right on time you know junior high
when kids started getting braces and I
remember this kid Sean he got somehow
hit in the mouth and when he got up like
the wires that go from like you know you
know they on each tooth they had like a
like a little [ __ ] central hub where
the wires would go through and like the
thing had like popped off the wired
popped off those things are still glued
on that's right and he had like two
wires sticking straight out of his mouth
I remember him get our bike making this
weird noise and he was bleeding and we
were all just standing like somebody get
applause but now they got Invisalign and
it's tremendous in you to in 13 well
depends on how [ __ ] up your teeth are
and how much you're willing to wear him
cuz I know somebody else that's getting
him and it doesn't want to wear him all
the time so she's giving in to the fact
that it's gonna take you know like a
year and a half or some [ __ ] and it's
just like why wouldn't you get it over
with and she was just like why wouldn't
she just [ __ ] off and I was like fine
hey fair enough fair enough
Who am I to tell you how to fix your
[ __ ] dentition all right I'm just you
know I'm excited I want other people to
be excited hey his son to be excited
about I finally watched I watched two
Bruins games this weekend yeah
Oh topo do I finally saw Rick Nash
playing with the Bruins faked physical
presence scored a goal on Saturday
now matinee game those games usually
suck right because they're [ __ ] teams
tired they just wakin up they used to
like they still shaken off a hangover
and all of a sudden that droppin the
puck there's a bunch of kids there and
[ __ ] it feels like feels like a charity
game you know doesn't feel like the
season but they played a wild one on
Saturday 7:00 to 4:00 they want they
were up to - nothing looking like it was
gonna be nice smooth [ __ ] time and
then the Hawks gave a seal right there
Fred then it was 2 to 2 I can't remember
3 2 3 3 4 3 4 4 5 or 6 for 74 right I
think that's what it was and then today
like - [ __ ] you know I thought we
were gonna we tied it up I thought we
had the goddamn thing one in the Charro
I know the Patrick Sharp took a stick to
the face from Chara said we got shower
in the box for four minutes up and major
for the rest of the goddamn game
right a double minor I should say and
then of course they go out there in the
[ __ ] it remind me when we lost the
Stanley Cup to him we're like oh there
is gonna be a game seven no there isn't
it's over they did that [ __ ] Patrick
Kane Jesus Christ guys is sniper so I'm
gonna try to watch some more of the
gains but I mean I've watched so many
[ __ ] games in the last ten years that
it didn't feel like I was away that long
and I still knew most of the team
because I've been watching looking at
the stats and all of that [ __ ] so I
don't know I guess I'll try I don't know
well now I got the kid man it's just
it's [ __ ] hard man I haven't been
able to watch my Celtics my Bruins you
know Patriots are easy cuz it's like
once a week you know so anyways I'm just
[ __ ] I'm meandering right now because
I'm waiting for the all the reads and
all that [ __ ] to come in because
there's always I have 50,000 [ __ ]
things I have to do today even on a
Sunday this is a day arrest even God
rested on Sunday I'm working harder than
God people I shouldn't have said that
you know this [ __ ] purse
sent me this doesn't I don't know this
[ __ ] thing where this guy was
convinced that I was possessed by Satan
and his eye for cinematography was
incredible the way he was breaking down
something I did he got every [ __ ]
thing that we were doing right he just
had the motivation wrong he was like
this is hypnotic they're trying to
hypnotize you it was all deserved Satan
and it's like no it's not to serve Satan
it's so I could sell tickets the reason
why there's no crowd shots is because I
feel your brain resets every time they
cut to the [ __ ] crowd and then you
gotta try to draw them in again when you
go to a [ __ ] stand-up show you're not
looking at the comedian and then turning
around looking at people laughing every
[ __ ] eight seconds that would be a
shitty experience so I'm trying to
recreate the live experience that's all
I'm doing I'm not trying to serve you
know the guy down under all right with
my stand-up special I do that
effortlessly the way I live my life
anyways but it's [ __ ] this YouTube
video this guy's compare and like
[ __ ] he goes look at the p90x oh god
they use black and white and they
[ __ ] do all this it was really it was
really insane my favorite part was when
he told his kid then knock it off he's a
good dad hey knock it off but yeah
anyways you're gonna get that right I
guess if you put a [ __ ] special out
you're gonna get some [ __ ] like that
what gives a [ __ ] about my stand-up
specialist you know it was awesome last
night I stayed in with my lovely
beautiful gorgeous wife and we hung in
and I started to watch peaky blinders
and you ever know nothin about no
robbery right she's like I don't want to
watch this all right bill you're white
enough I have a difficult time enough
understanding you forget about these
[ __ ] people right so I was like okay
fair enough so then we were scrolling
through and I look for the nice guys
once again Netflix can you make my year
and get the nice guys starring Russell
Crowe and Jesus why forget this guy's
name
I got from Drive the guy from lala land
I'll remember later I always the [ __ ] is
his name
he's [ __ ] hilarious in that movie too
you know [ __ ] this hang on a second I'm
gonna hit pause I gotta get this guy's
name sorry Ryan Gosling they're [ __ ]
hilarious in that move rank awesome
Solaris Russell Crowe's hilarious it's
such an underrated comedy and it reminds
me of one of my favorite comedies of all
time midnight run as far as I feel like
the comedy so much of it their reactions
in the way they're doing things it's it
comes from a real place
I don't mind wacky I don't mind absurd
earning that [ __ ] but uh I [ __ ]
love that movie and so I looked it up
and for whatever reason Netflix has
every [ __ ] movie just about on this
streaming service the biggest streaming
service in the world world right but
they don't have that one so I'm like
[ __ ] and we scrolled down and then they
had Thelma and Louise and I was just
like man I have not I literally not seen
that movie since I saw it when it came
out in the movies and uh oh is that a
great [ __ ] movie [ __ ] great
goddamn movie and it still holds up but
now with all this me to [ __ ] you watch
it now and it's it's more relevant than
ever and every guy in there was just as
piece of [ __ ] hitting on him like the
guy who plays Geena Davis's husband
Christopher McDonald he fought he
[ __ ] steals every scene that he's in
like you got it you got to watch it
again when they tell him that his wife
might be involved in her murder murder
he just goes what wait what just the way
I'm gonna bump what you're in it he's
[ __ ] hilarious in that movie and we
watched it in the end you know I don't
ruin the ending for people who haven't
seen it but a
you know anything that you know is a
little nod to vanishing point you got to
love that if you ever seen vanishing
point that's one of the first like
anti-hero was during that not the first
but during that era of the anti-hero
like up until then I guess with movies
and [ __ ] it was always like you know the
guy with the white hat and who's kidding
who the white skin was always like the
[ __ ] hero he was always trying to do
the right thing he didn't Rob he didn't
steal and he was a [ __ ] hero and if
you stole and you were a piece of [ __ ]
you wore the black hat you were the bad
guy you know what I mean I would say
that they put minorities in those roles
but way back then I didn't think they
did that they just had like they even
had white people playing like Native
Americans in agents even agents I
remember that when I posted that thing
from [ __ ] Hawaii five-o and they had
that [ __ ] white dude and they they
did something to his eyes to try to make
him look he just looked weird which was
really strange because they had all
those I don't know if they were whole
Asian Hawaiian what the [ __ ] they were
but I mean they had plenty of people who
weren't white on that show I don't know
didn't make any sense but anyways you
got to love Jack Lords mercury mock I
liked the first one they did the 67 that
he had are the 66 that was a mean
[ __ ] looking car anyways but we sat
we watched that movie and it still it
still holds up it still [ __ ] holds up
this is a time when usually I would
start doing some reads but I don't
[ __ ] have any film in my reads out
Jesus bill why would you make such a bad
[ __ ] joke you know I can't even sign
into my [ __ ] gmail right now I don't
know what the problem is
Oh Instagram I'm instinct I'm inching
closer to getting on Instagram I figured
out what my password is and now they're
like that has been too many [ __ ] up
attempts to get into your account Mike
all right that was me but there's nobody
to say that to so they go we're gonna
send this [ __ ] code to you and then
they never send it well whose kid who
they sent me something back in September
and I never [ __ ] responded so now I
think they're looking at my
uh you know my account like it's [ __ ]
up or some [ __ ] I have no idea but
anyways what gives a [ __ ] enough about
that
oh so thank you to everybody who who
came out to my shows in Vancouver Jesus
Christ that I have a good time I had
such a [ __ ] great time performing up
there such a beautiful city and all that
and this woman started running down to
this stage she was yelling something
about how lesbians were better at
something I was just like what I don't
know what you're talking about
and you know and I was being an [ __ ]
you know it's making fun of all that me
to [ __ ] you know just you know feminists
you did just so easy to get mad how do
you not do it it's just so [ __ ]
tempting as a comic so I'm up there just
saying this [ __ ] ridiculous
ignorant [ __ ] and everybody's laughing
including all the rest of the women
there cuz they know what I'm saying is
so [ __ ] ridiculous they know I don't
believe it right but nowadays there's
there's always the you know Franny
face-value
in the [ __ ] crowd right you got to
[ __ ] take everything like they'd hate
me now I'm offended
now I'm offended so I don't know what
the [ __ ] she was doing she started like
marching down towards the stage and all
this security came and just got her in a
way and next note next thing I knew she
was being escorted out which sucked cuz
that meant the fun was over I heard
people aside some friends that came out
to the show they were trying its people
walking out saying that she was a plant
how funny is that like I got that kind
of time and money to fly an actor up to
[ __ ] Vancouver to interrupt my show
it's just like at that point when I just
hired somebody to write me better
material who knows I don't have no idea
I don't know why people always think
that that's such an old showbiz thing to
have a plant in the crowd but people
used to do it they did used to do it so
I guess it's fair that they that they
that they think that but anyway so she
got kicked out I never kick anybody on
the show it wasn't my call either they
just [ __ ] escorted her out
which I thought was funny after I mean I
kind of felt bad I was like well you
know we've been fine she stuck around I
could hear it some more of her [ __ ]
crazy theories you know I don't know I
don't there's this and I had I had
another two women walked out on my show
when I was down the improv now if I was
some sort of thinking man I would be
like why hey bill that's two incidents
in one week maybe it's you but you know
I really don't think it is I just think
that the the extreme left are out of
their [ __ ] minds now and they have
this thing where if you if that there's
only one way to think and it's their way
and there's only certain subjects you
can joke about and if they don't think
that you should be joking about it that
they're just gonna really just behave
like children it was funny when they got
up and walked out when I was at the
improv like people were gonna care I
don't know hey you know what you know
what it's just the world that we're
living in huh just this overly sensitive
[ __ ] time that we're living and so
anyways uh the [ __ ] am I gonna get these
reads hey did you see Trump is gonna go
talk to Kim Jong then they gotta go hang
out so I actually looked up the [ __ ]
story right I look this story up let me
see if I can find this [ __ ] and my first
thought when I saw that picture side to
side is like you know Trump gets way too
much [ __ ] for his [ __ ] hairdo the
picture they have on the Google News his
hair looks good to me
you know I think it was bad for a long
time where he had he did have a
comb-over but since then hair plugs got
way better and I think he filled it in
but he likes having the big swoop and
thing cuz I think that's part of his
look but I think that's all his hair but
whatever but Kim Jong ons haircut huh oh
[ __ ] you say Jesus Christ I don't want
to sabotage this meeting but my god he
has like a Joseph Stalin meets mole
Howard with a little bit of John
Travolta all in the same
all in the same [ __ ] haircut it's
incredible really is it's like the kind
of haircut like a wrestler you know
would have they wanted to make a splash
like oh my god who the [ __ ] is this guy
but anyways didn't you imagine the balls
let me just sitting here [ __ ]
completely bald sit in their trash in
these people's haircuts I gave Trump
nodded I don't think looks like bad
compared to what compared to what I'm
[ __ ] dealing with I guess although I
think I look better than hey well let's
do that let's do that on the Photoshop
you know they go who wore it best you
know do a [ __ ] Trump me and Kim Jong
and just vote worst haircut and [ __ ] all
you [ __ ] who pick me just to be
[ __ ] I respect it but [ __ ] you too
alright CIA director Mike Pompeo has
defended Donald Trump's decision to meet
North Korean leader Kim jong-un saying
the president understands the risk I
actually think it's [ __ ] great that
he's doing this this should happen more
go talk it out before a bunch of people
[ __ ] die you lunatics he said mr.
Trump isn't doing this for theater he's
going there to solve a problem the spy
chief told Fox News Sunday it's funny
he's a spa a spa a spy and he's going on
the [ __ ] news the president has said
the summit could produce the greatest
deal for the world
what else would he say he's been saying
that that's how it got him in the office
everything's great but critics have
warned that it's a tough talks go poorly
the two nations will be in a worse
position than before it's the political
gamble of the 21st century that the
tricky task of preparing for the Trump
Kim summit why is everybody so flike why
is it better if that the two of them
don't talk says no sitting US president
has ever met a North Korean leader mr.
Trump reportedly accepted the offer to
do so on the spot when it was relayed by
South Korea South Korean envoy on
Thursday taking his own administration
by surprise let me ask you this please
tell me they're not going
meet some [ __ ] Italian restaurant in
the village okay and if any point
kim-jong
says I need to go to the bathroom
alright you better you better have
something down by your ankles that's all
I'm saying
anyways attempts to negotiate aid for
disarmament deals have failed repeatedly
since 2003 when the North pulled out of
the nuclear non-proliferation treaty mr.
Pompeo told CBS the administration had
its eyes wide open to the challenge of
dealing with North Korea I gotta be
honest with you I don't understand what
the [ __ ] problem is like why are
there do we have like economic sanctions
on them is that why their people are
starving and we have that on them
because they were part of the Communists
expansion you know there's got to be a
better way to do it we gotta you know
economic sanctions we why don't you go
the other way why don't we ever go the
other way and just become like the the
[ __ ] you know just be like a good
[ __ ] you know fight the guy to the Super
Bowl get him some [ __ ] you know then
he doesn't want to blow this place up
yeah I can't [ __ ] blow that up and I
go to the football game I got my dick
sucked what are we doing here I like
those guys right it's like when the
Bruins in the Rangers hated each other
and then they all played on the same
team and they went and they played the
Russians and all of a sudden the rivalry
[ __ ] died that's what you do these
people they got they got a hangout you
know I don't know how good that'll be
for the rest of us cuz then they're
probably like Joint Forces I have no
[ __ ] idea so I don't read the news I
mean it's Princess Diana's iconic
minefield walk what the [ __ ] is this
about how slow a news day is it that
they're gonna bring this [ __ ] up I mean
then I was like she died what ninety
seven Rosa Parks for Rosa Parks there
was a fifteen year old girl from Iiro
too big friend is Bernie Sanders running
for president five women five countries
five babies that sounds like a bad movie
doesn't
the man Brussels can't stop Brussels
can't stop talking about that's the
winner right there who's this guy's
Brussels can't stop the man at the heart
of the Brussels saga saga I have no idea
what this is about the European
Commission has denied allegations of
cronyism after a protege of its
president jean-claude Juncker was given
one of the most powerful jobs in the EU
civil service yet everybody hooks
everybody up in politics Martin's cell
mayor has been appointed
secretary-general General of the
Commission on Martin st. Mahler cell
mayor the organization that monitors
whether countries are sticking to e use
rules dreams up new laws and runs the
brexit talks day to day who is he
he's a 40-something Lord who gives a
[ __ ] this is why I can't pay who who
cares I don't care I actually stopped
carrying the middle of that all right I
guess I have to hit pause at this point
cuz I don't have any my [ __ ]
advertising a [ __ ] or just can't
talk to you about oh you know what my
[ __ ] shoulder is doing great I did
yoga for 20 minutes before my shoulder
was like you know getting a little like
hey take it easy there huh I got
weightlifting going again a little bit I
got to get in shape girls you know the
pink oh my god you had a girl 1-pounders
I got the baby blue [ __ ] five
pounders and I don't know at some point
I'm gonna work back up to the iron but
at this point all my all my weight
training with this [ __ ] I grab looks
like it's made out of play-doh but uh
I'm [ __ ] psyched because I told you
guys I mean I'm turned 50 I know if I
brought that up for fifty thousand
[ __ ] times but I'm turning fifty in
June and I'm gonna get into the best
shape of my life that's what I plan on
doing that's my plan whether I do it or
not I have no idea not the best shape in
my life
best shape of my [ __ ] like the last
10 years because matter how good a shape
I get in you know the parts of 50 years
old right you know they always trying to
say that [ __ ] you know least to do that
[ __ ] was just like you know I did a test
you know I'm 50 but my [ __ ] legs are
40 it's like no no they're not those are
your those are all original parts
okay unless you lost the leg and then
they stuck a new one on there when you
were 10 then that leg would be 40 years
old the prosthetic alright that was
negative all right let me let me hit
pause here all right and I'm back that
was half a second in your life but uh
alright I guess oh geez we got a new
advertiser here
my bookie over there my bookie for those
of you people out there like to gamble
on sports I like these guys cuz they're
not trying to act like you know this is
a game of skill they're like your bookie
my bookie
my bookie hey guys it's time to talk to
you about the boatload of money you can
make this week by betting at my bookie
oh Jesus Christ if you haven't checked
them out this is the perfect time to get
in into the action the mad the madness
of March is here all right guys gamble
responsibly cuz you know I'm gonna bet
you know I bet on stuff okay but let's
see don't put your house up okay this is
what the bookies are no different than
then ar-15s okay it's it's all how you
use them all right if you haven't
checked them out this is the perfect
time to get into the action the madness
of March is here put down some money and
score big on college hoops
join me and thousands of online players
and start betting at my bookie dot AG I
don't bet online but I wouldn't even
know how to [ __ ] begin to do this I
can't even get into my own Instagram
account that's just a generic line that
they give every host okay but you know
if you hear you this is what you can
[ __ ] gamble if you think you know
what you're talking about put your money
where your mouth is are you sick and
tired of getting the runaround when you
ask for your payout I would only
recommend a service to I to you I guess
I'm supposed to say to you that's been
good to me and our listeners this is my
first [ __ ] read they even have in
game live betting so you can even place
a bet after tip-off chase your money
join now and my bookie will match your
first deposit with
the 50% bonus you can even enter for a
chance to win their million-dollar
bracket challenge somebody always hits
that right there use promo code Burpee
you are our to activate offer visit my
bookie today play win and get paid or
play lose and get yelled at those are
your options
yeah what do you know I wonder how the
mob thinks about what these [ __ ]
people are doing is cutting in on our
action over here but a being but I'm
actually I'm actually gonna gamble you
know I should I should use my bookie why
not I'll throw a [ __ ] hundred bucks
on March Madness when does it start
who's playing huh that's what most
people say what's the game I'll throw a
[ __ ] they'll throw a c-note in
alright the black tux everybody this
isn't the me - black tux at everybody
war this is just the one for [ __ ]
regular people who didn't take the dick
out at work I need to prove that they
didn't okay this is for classy people
not these animals here in Hollywood
alright I try to make things up with a
certain colored shirt rather than
adjusting a behavior okay this is a
class act here this is civilian outside
of Hollywood black tuxedos alright for
more than a year now I've been talking
about the black tux calm the black tux
it never gets old because they always
have new and exciting styles for your
next big event whether you're a stylist
selected outfit or building a custom
look the black tux has tons of new suits
and tuxedos to choose from for your big
spring events the black tux is always
changing up their looks making it fun to
try out different suits and tuxedos even
if you have your own suit switching it
up with the black tux is always a great
idea yeah it is a great idea something
different it comes all steamed and ready
to go you throw it on your twirl your
[ __ ] lady around the dance floor you
come on you give it back to them done
over I was kind of creepy and then
someone else wears it to something else
just imagine all the memories that are
in there right it's like a [ __ ] I
don't know what it is
some reason I thought no I can't see
what I just thought I and what I don't
know why just look I'll tell you later
what I was thinking of and with their
new fit algorithm you don't have to
awkwardly measure yourself or ask a
friend for help yeah the black tux does
it for you plus the black tux free home
try on lets you see the fit and feel the
quality of your suit months before your
event after ordering your suit will
arrive for 14 days before your event and
remember how simple returns are wear it
turn heads then send it back three days
after your event shipping is free both
ways stand out at your event for the
right reasons with the black tux to get
a $20 $20 off your purchase visit the
black tux comm / / that's the black tux
comm / / for $20 off your purchase the
black tux premium rental suits and
tuxedos delivered this is what you can
wear wear after you win all your money
on my bookie look at that tying
everything together oh oh look who's
back
ah but who do me on these B undies
putting on your [ __ ] black tux - doo
doo doo me ADIZ me undies why did she
suck all those [ __ ] because she wanted
a part in a movie she was in not one not
two but three because she played that
[ __ ] game and now how the [ __ ] is she
ever going to get any more work you know
how a [ __ ] is gonna handle this whole
[ __ ] post me - some women will
probably I'll [ __ ] it I'll do it
get over here you [ __ ] warthog anyway
so you've heard me talk about me undies
and you know that I am a big believer in
their product they're the perfect
balance of comfortable fit every month
they have a new and exciting Prince and
they arrive at your door in a fun bag
the undies uses lensing micro mode al
modal in their underwear
it's a sustainably sourced I don't know
what that means naturally soft fiber
that does that mean if you cut down a
tree
you make this underwear you plant
another one a modal tree motel naturally
soft fiber that starts with the
beechwood trees and ends with the most
amazing fabrics you've ever experienced
the results have been downright dreamy
it's incredible that this these things
are made out of wood you know how do you
not get splinters in your [ __ ] ball
bag there now a little picket fence
along your taint the undies adventurous
prints are design and designs are all
limited edition and new patterns are
released every few weeks on a rolling
basis one under percent satisfaction
guarantee me undies guarantees you you
will love your undies or your money back
how the [ __ ] do they keep coming up with
new designs is beyond me the undies a
sure you love your underwear they offer
a 100% satisfaction guarantee if you
don't love your first bear if you don't
love it you'll get a full refund this is
a no brainer and you get to keep the
underwear so willing to take it back
wash it give it to somebody else
get 20% off you a pair of the most
comfortable under underwear you'll ever
put on to get your 20% off your first
pair of free shipping 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to me undies com / / that's
me undies com / / oh we got another one
simply safe I've got some exciting news
simply save a home security company I've
worked with since they were a stat up
I've watched them transform into the
fastest-growing home security company in
the nation protecting over 2 million
people
why didn't I invest in this well they
just released their brand-new home
security system the all-new simply safe
this system has been completely rebuilt
and redesigned they've added new
safeguards to protect against power
outages downed Wi-Fi cut landlines bats
hammers and everything in between
what bats like the [ __ ] things that
fly hammers or they mean like thieves
showing up with weapons I don't know
what that means the only simply safe was
redesigned to be practically invisible
with the power sensors with power
sensors so small you'll hardly notice
them
you know you know when intruders oh you
know who will intrude it's not wind you
know we're well intruders they're gonna
notice all that [ __ ] okay this is what
truly remark this is what's truly
remarkable to me simply safe spent years
building this system they added so much
but you still get the same fair and
honest price 24/7 protection for only
$15 a month and there's no contract it's
smaller faster and stronger than
anything they've built before but supply
is very limited visits simply safe
birbee you are are calm now to order
that simply safe burg calm protected
protect your home and family today
simply safe bird calm you know what I
was wondering like can you also use that
[ __ ] to like catch your roommates
stealing your [ __ ] you know go into your
[ __ ] I rub alright lastly but not
leastly stamps.com stamp calm never
closes print postage for letters or
packages at your convenience
24/7 mail everything from postcards to
envelopes to packages domestic or
international creates your stamp calm
account in minutes online with no
equipment to lease and no long-term
commitments click print and mail and
you're done they'll send you a digital
scale automatically calculates exact
postage stamps comm will even help you
decide the best class of mail based on
your needs I use that your needs I use
stamps calm and I would be using it this
year when I come up with a poster for my
[ __ ] tour when I ship them out to
these venues and I'm a [ __ ] if I can
figure out how to use it so can you and
right now you service I don't know like
you peony with this special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage
and a digital scale go to stamps comm
click on the microphone stop the
homepage and type in BER that stamps.com
enter BER okay I just realized I left
the monitor in the other room I don't
want my daughter to wake up without me
all right hang on
all right you know what she's still
sleeping
and I just realized that it's not 4:15
it's 5:15
so I need to wake her up I hate having
to wake her up but I got to do that or
else she's gonna throw her all off
alright I gotta hit pause again hitting
pause again right I'm back he's back
right I was all set to launch into why
postmates sucks as I finally downloaded
it onto my phone the app and I was like
I ride him and do what all the kids are
doing bah bah bah bah bah bah Oh order
the food and some [ __ ] kids gonna
show up in the oven
you know they can't [ __ ] ring a
doorbell anymore they sitting there they
texting you that they're outside that
had not been a so anyways I've used it
twice
same place okay the first [ __ ] guy
say I said I did I live on [ __ ] nine
million eight hundred fifty eight Main
Street North Main Street he went to the
south main street he's just like go up
well I black 89 miles boom yo what the
[ __ ] code it's not how we talked he was
actually a good [ __ ] and I set that
blaming myself go and I probably [ __ ]
it up I just signed up about it all his
[ __ ] [ __ ] and turned out I didn't
[ __ ] up I put my rights at copán and
they they they [ __ ] up I still tipped
the guy right I got a need to be liked
he was a good guy whatever so I ordered
it again same [ __ ] place and I'm
waiting and I'm waiting and then I'm
looking and it says it's gonna be here
at like 6 and I'm like fine you know but
I can't negotiate it and then [ __ ] I
don't know I hit something and it said
oops it's been a problem you order can't
go through so I was just like hey
[ __ ] [ __ ] post mates and all this
[ __ ] and ate something else and in the
middle of prepping that the doorbell
rings the money order came so I don't
know what I did so I apologize to post
mates for all the [ __ ] I just said about
him walking around my house evidently I
[ __ ] it up I went back to some other
screen all I knew is I couldn't tell if
I ordered it and had gone through I
don't know and you know it doesn't take
much to
can you no sorry I'm taking my past what
I can't [ __ ] thinking type at the
same time it doesn't take much to throw
me off that's all I'm saying alright so
whatever post mates is fine okay alright
bill tour dates second and third late
shows added to some of these dates oh
nice nice nice baby boo boo boo boo doo
doo doo doo Oh [ __ ] Billy big heads
got a [ __ ] tour he's doing I'm gonna
be in Kitchener Ontario March 7th we
added a Late Show I'm sorry March 17th
Oh
st. Paddy's Day - Lulla Lulla and the
green alligator and the
something-something and along a goose
caught him aggregor in a [ __ ]
something all right
Tulsa Oklahoma March 30th when it's an
Antonio we added a show March 31st we
added a Late Show in Pittsburgh April
6th we added a Late Show and Cincinnati
April 7th as I go through the [ __ ]
and I've ceased AFC Central for the old
AFC Central Division Nashville we added
a Late Show April 21st San Francisco I'm
there the four may 14 15 16 and 17 17th
is the only day with tickets left look
at you [ __ ] guy showing up for the
ball thank you
that I'm doing the three Arena and
Dublin Ireland and then I'm doing Royal
Albert Hall in London England can you
believe that if you [ __ ] think that
I'm not setting up an old Ludwig kid
there during the [ __ ] a day and playing
a bunch of Zeppelin when the place is
empty yeah you don't know me I'm gonna
do that unless they tell me I can't then
I'll be like oh sorry didn't mean to
offend the Queen whatever the [ __ ] I'm
supposed to say added a Late Show in
Minneapolis on June 29th we added a late
showed Seattle July 15th or other ones
what other ones alright whatever you'll
see all this [ __ ] you'll see all this
[ __ ]
where I'm gonna be at oh man well this
is gonna be a fun year it's gonna be a
fun year all right enough of me [ __ ]
drooling over all those great places I
get to perform at Boston sports hey
there Billy Russell do you think Boston
is the type of city that could have
supported two teams in any sport do you
think it's something you could handle in
the future Thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
well we had that opportunity way back in
the day we had the let's see we had the
the Boston Braves and the Boston Red Sox
the Braves ended up leaving I don't know
I don't know I gotta be honest with you
I don't know how the Brooklyn Nets did
it where all those people out there with
Knick fans and then all of a sudden the
New Jersey Knicks move out there and it
just says Brooklyn and everybody just
jumps on the bandwagon and says [ __ ] the
Knicks I don't get that especially if
you're a long time suffering Knicks fan
and then what if they win it you know
even if then Brooklyn Nets win it it's
not going to be the same you didn't
[ __ ] they showed up during your life
you know that's like the second wife you
don't love her the way you love the
first one because the first one went bad
I would think right I don't know and
then of course we had two football teams
there for a minute we had the New
England Patriots and we had the Boston
Breakers in the USFL I went to a game
against the Washington Federals and Nick
Nicholson field I know I don't I don't
you know this is the deal we don't need
more than one team in every sport the
way New York does to try to [ __ ] win
some championships I'm telling you the
[ __ ] New York Yankees are the sugar
daddy of New York City right that's the
reason why New York City is not looked
upon is one of the most pathetic [ __ ]
sports towns ever just--can spent
considering the amount of titles versus
the amount of [ __ ] teams you know
NIC's haven't won in forever the nets
have never won the Med 71 and
30-something years the Jets haven't won
since Super Bowl [ __ ] three who else
the next you know the next since what 73
the Rangers have won once since 1940 and
they're going on a 25 year [ __ ]
drought again they're about halfway
through that [ __ ] curse again already
just like that they went 54 years the
last time they're almost at the halfway
point of that Giants a decent Giants are
respectable they know so they did a bye
you know some Gentiles will want some
NFL titles too so but what kills the
[ __ ] City for me aside from my blind
hatred of them is the fact that you know
you can just go oh what about the Giants
cuz you already have the Jets so that
you don't to have the Jets hanging
around your neck oh the [ __ ] meadow
what about the Yankees you know I mean
they always have like a [ __ ] option
so yeah I don't know I gotta be honest
with you I don't understand how the
Clippers [ __ ] survive but they do
they do I just don't see that happening
in a city like Boston the size of it and
the the ridiculous loyalty that you
would bring a new team like who the [ __ ]
would you bring in there I mean
everybody hates us at this point in
everybody's talk [ __ ] about us so what
are we gonna move there
the Jaguars the New England jag was
would you put him on Wooster change
their name the [ __ ] Worcester
wildebeest I don't know
former vegetarian and anti weightlifter
dear Billy bison thighs heard you
talking about lifting weights with Kenny
Aronoff I just read that sentence again
heard you talking about lifting weights
with Kenny Aronoff how [ __ ] awesome
was he on the podcast I can't believe I
got to meet that guy really glad you
understand the benefits I was a
vegetarian who only did cardio for five
and a half years I recently started
eating Hamill fat again and I feel a lot
better
not going to preach against veget anair
vegetarianism but the mental benefits of
those types of cholesterol is complete
improved my hormone energy and cognitive
levels I only eat grass fed meat and try
to eat in the morning to improve brain
function also since I started lifting
weights once or twice a week my upper
body feels better than when doing when
doing basic tasks around the house and
yard what's your take on red meat are
you picky where it comes from
now do it I literally fell eat a [ __ ]
cow late eat another cow I don't have I
don't have the patience there's a
butcher you know a couple of towns over
I guess I could go too sometimes I go
there but generally speaking I don't
know what I'm eating but I try to eat as
well as I can
what's my take on red meat it's [ __ ]
delicious you know I start to read up on
all of that [ __ ] it just gets so [ __ ]
depressing so I try me and then you go
through that they just say it's
grass-fed okay so it's grass-fed
everything says it's [ __ ] organic it
isn't organic it's got a bunch of crap
put in there like the system to monitor
what's in your food like most systems at
this point is so [ __ ] corrupt I don't
I don't know how to I don't know what to
do but uh yeah I'm actually I I will go
back to lifting weights I don't think
I'm gonna do like bench pressing I'll do
it with dumbbells for some reason with
dumbbells I can control the angle
independently on both shoulders and I
don't have a [ __ ] problem but uh
bench pressing is for young people and I
am NOT young alright for a Mont gun laws
bill I'm from New Hampshire and I always
found it fascinating how lenient
Vermont's gun laws are here's a basic
rundown of how Bernie runs things and
why he's always careful around the gun
law conversation
minimum age to pursue purchase and
possess in Vermont Vermont allows any
person age 16 or older to possess a
handgun without the consent of a parent
or guardian there is no minimum age to
possess a rifle or a shotgun in Vermont
Vermont law allows firearm sales to
anyone 16 years or older thanks alright
well I really don't have a problem with
any of that I just have a problem with
people who are mentally ill getting them
that's the problem and nobody on either
side seems to know how to stop that from
happening
you know I think guys that [ __ ]
people who buy guns keep making this guy
made this whole video showing how like
that this this rifle he had had a bullet
twice the size of an ar-15 going but
this is the this is the friendly gun
nobody's scared of this one and it's got
a boat twice you know what this saying
you know what they're saying and
everybody's just gotta [ __ ] just sit
there and act like they don't understand
what the eff doesn't everybody want this
[ __ ] to stop somebody for the love of
[ __ ] god just come figure out how to
[ __ ] you can't be a [ __ ] nutjob and
just walk in and get a [ __ ] gun
that's the [ __ ] problem but people
who like to buy guns don't want it to be
extra difficult for them to get the
[ __ ] thing because they're not nuts
so which is crazy to me
I don't you know yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah but watching both of
those arguments they're talking about
two totally different [ __ ] things one
sighs just like a beautiful all of the
guns stupid guns are great guns do great
things okay
they think you can defend yourself with
the gun and you can provide you can hunt
with the gun okay you can scare somebody
off with the [ __ ] again this is great
[ __ ] things and then there's bad
things you could do with the gun it's a
hell an invention hell of an invention
all right wife unable to grow the [ __ ]
up
hey there Billy said old sober ballsack
now I'm not sober anymore
I got a rack of bud tall sitting in the
fridge I love a Budweiser every once in
a while and it can takes me back to when
I first got shit-faced down Fanueil Hall
been a listener for few years actually I
was drinking Michelob light that night
I'm a particular I'm particularly a fan
of the way you look at sensitive topics
like religion not everyone is able to
question the fact of why all other
religions sound silly like our own I
love that bit on your special well thank
you you know as much as you loved it
somebody else thought I was a servant of
Satan now for the question I'm a guy on
my early 30s you mean in my early 30s
married with a beaut with a beautiful
two-year-old daughter Congrats on yours
by the way it's a wonderful thing being
a father yes it is however my wife
routinely gets nostalgic about her
teenage years she's unable to get a
steady job keeps changing topics it's
it's school so she attends a certain
course for a couple years gives up heads
on to the next one I was hoping becoming
a mom would help but it looks like it
hasn't recently she's even been asking
how upset would I be if she told me she
was cheating what the [ __ ] that's a help
she has apparently been watching some
[ __ ] show on Netflix where the
protagonist is a chick that cheats to
feel free and young again isn't it [ __ ]
it's just women I swear to [ __ ] god I
swear to God do you know if they have I
put a show on the [ __ ] air where a
guy was cheating on his wife to feel
free and young again the amount of
[ __ ] attacks that that goddamn show
would get you know this is one thing
that I have learned generally when it
comes to women okay if you [ __ ] up it's
your fault
okay it's your fault if they [ __ ] up
it's because of something you did that's
kind of how it works I told her I think
that's [ __ ] I can go out on a guys
night out smoke a cigar drink some
alcohol and have a [ __ ] great time
and that's basically more than enough
for me unfortunately I have also found
out she's been trying to engage in
conversation with their first big crush
oh boy dude like I D you know you don't
have to be a genius to read these tea
leaves here man at least the way you're
presenting it so what she takes on this
what the [ __ ] do I do with this woman
we're planning on having a second child
but honestly I'm not sure if it's a good
idea it's fine for me to stay with my
daughter and she can [ __ ] off if that's
what she wants I almost think you have
to tell her that I'll find out first
what's just be like what's going on with
you you're asking me how I would feel if
you cheated on me you're watching this
show with this woman's cheating and
you're having conversations with your
first big crush okay I need to know
what's going on are you going through a
phase because if this [ __ ] thing's
over it's [ __ ] over I'm not having
another kid with you
and I wouldn't get upset the way I'm
getting upset for you to say it I would
just put it online like what's going on
with you and I don't know how much I
would trust her listen to what she has
to say and before I have another kid
with that person I would [ __ ] I would
hire a private investigator to follow
her around to see if she's not [ __ ]
somebody else no I wouldn't but you
should by the way I'm she said I'm doing
very well professionally and have also
some hobbies that keep me entertained
having a daughter certainly takes a toll
on a relationship I'm guessing she's had
she has too much free time and maybe
consequently feels neglected we do try
to watch a show every now and then and
we go out as a family regularly on the
weekend sex life is okay not sure if we
can blame this situation on me thanks a
lot
well God knows she's gonna
I mean what man doesn't feel [ __ ]
neglected to when they have a kid I mean
your sex life does suffer you know so
you then go out and you know do
something to feel free it wanted yeah
you need to sit down and talk to her
find out what the [ __ ] is going on
and I would just tell what you're doing
and the way you make me feel right now
is not even remotely fair and it's not
something I would do to you so what the
[ __ ] just clean that up say it in a nice
way man that's [ __ ] annoying there's
a show out there where a woman [ __ ]
around to feel free and young again
listen here's the thing all right it's
not that I even [ __ ] mind that show
because I believe that there are people
out there like this people out there
that they're just not designed to be
married there's people out there that
can actually do that and it doesn't mean
[ __ ] to them both men and women and they
can just [ __ ] walk back in it doesn't
mean [ __ ] to and the problem is the
person they're with it means something
too so I'm pretty [ __ ] open-minded
but I've just annoyed that if you made
it you know did they go I guess it was
Californication like that I have no idea
I never watch that show I couldn't get
into that show I didn't get what this
guy's problem was ah man you know these
[ __ ] young chicks just want to keep
banging me I'm supposed to feel bad for
this guy anyway friend's wife is
attracted to meet you dear billiard the
cue ball the cue balls I like that
appreciate the podcast and everything
you do and thank you for taking the time
to read this email no problem thank you
for the funny nickname I like it I'm in
a tricky situation here there are four
people involved my buddy of 12 years oh
man his wife of two years dude where's
your loyalty my girlfriend of six months
and myself we were all in our mid to
late 20s
oh boy it has recently come to light
that the wife is interested in me oh
jesus oh you just skipped over a lot of
[ __ ] details how did that come about
she said you have Valentine oh you guys
having inappropriate conversation that
led to that
anyways I met her about three years ago
while she and my buddy were still just
dating
she was my type and I was drawn to her
immediately she is at least a nine for
my taste but I just put her in the
unattainable compartment in my brain
since she wasn't available I did not
give her any additional thought beyond
being cordial I didn't really care to
get to know her and I didn't think about
what it would be like to date her though
if she had been single I would have gone
after it all right so so far according
to you you've been a good guy
fast-forward to the recent past my
buddy's wife and I got to know each
other on a bit more of a personal level
on my birthday a few months ago my
girlfriend was there too and it seemed
like my buds wife took an interest in
getting to know my girlfriend as well
since then the four of us have hung out
a few times and the wife has gotten to
know me a lot better I have also been
hitting the gym which has gotten the
attention of my buddy's wife Jesus
Christ all right they've been married
two years you're 20 in your late 20s so
she's looking to pull the ripcord where
the [ __ ] was I okay so one weekend a
group of people including myself and my
buddy's wife go to a club my girlfriend
was invited but decided to go to sleep
instead obviously alcohol was flowing
and there isn't much room on a dance
floor I'll spare you the details still
what do mean spare me the details it was
just getting good [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
this is like a Cinemax movie I'll spare
you the details and suffice to say that
I learned that night that she was into
me when what she was doing the running
man on your dick I
I don't know okay I was pretty
overwhelmed and thrilled because I
thought she was a bit out of my league
I'm also I'm also am NOT the happiest in
my relationship what makes it harder for
me to sort out my feelings on the matter
this girl excels in the areas that my
girlfriend doesn't I'm I certainly am
very attracted to her and enjoy this
type of attention I didn't know if she
was unhappy in a relationship of what
I've tried to see what this girl wants
or if this a problem with her marriage
but she has had a lot of dodgy answers
like I wasn't looking for anything or
this isn't supposed to go anywhere or
I'm perfectly happy in my relationship
etc she also has a hard time committing
to any boundaries I'll [ __ ] this chick
[ __ ] this chick well maybe she just got
drunk and said something stupid it all
sounds like [ __ ] to me I think she
is lacking affection from my buddy and
she's bored and horny she also sounds
like she just doesn't want to admit that
there's a problem she's trying to have
the security of a marriage in the thrill
of a new romance we haven't kissed or
anything yet big word yet but I feel
like we've already desecrated both of
our relationships I also feel like any
increased fun talked about and the
tension will eventually reach the
inevitable breaking point yeah you got
to stay away from her what should I do
my girlfriend will lose her [ __ ] if she
hears about this my buddy will be really
unhappy I think you flipped those I
think your girlfriend be unhappy your
buddy will reuse his [ __ ] anyways and I
already feel like I couldn't trust this
girl if we did get together however I
don't really care I just love to hook up
with her I can well it's honest I can
tell this girl has something wacky going
on but I don't have the strength to
reject her advances what should I do
thank you so much and go [ __ ] yourself I
stopped going out to the club with them
or [ __ ] rub one out before you go out
or don't drink when you go out there
yeah that's gonna blow up that is gonna
[ __ ] blow up in your face
but who's kidding who meant that type of
[ __ ] happens all the [ __ ] time all
the [ __ ] time married women
we'll come up to another guy and say
that they're attracted to him I mean
there's all this [ __ ] out there now
about guy's behavior and that type of
[ __ ] you know women do it all the
[ __ ] time and they say they're better
at it I don't think they necessarily are
I think what the thing is is that just
women are into vengeance so you know
they you know if you get like something
like that going and if the end if they
don't get a [ __ ] check for a million
dollars in a house they're gonna try to
do something to blow up your life that's
what they do
guys we walk away [ __ ] you [ __ ] and we
just we generally speaking we just we
walk away they don't they burn down your
[ __ ] life
so dude there it first of all break up
with the [ __ ] check you're with now
and go find somebody else to [ __ ] around
with all right you don't need to be
[ __ ] around with your buddies unhappy
wife cuz you're never gonna be able to
trust her all right
you just not and then you're gonna lose
your friendship with 12 years with this
other guy all right this is basically
like your dicks in Congress right now
like filibustering you know you dick has
the floor right now
that's what the problem is if you just
sit down okay and you listed all the
pros and cons of doing this if you were
where I was at right now sitting there
the answer is easy don't do that don't
do that but when you're in it and your
dick is they're all [ __ ] logic goes
out the [ __ ] window so you know III
don't know I I just you know III would
just [ __ ] she said there's nothing
else to it I would leave it at that and
if she brings it up again I would just
say look you said there was nothing to
it okay so I don't want to hear anymore
that kind of talk
I already do it you can't hang out with
her anymore you can't you cannot [ __ ]
hang out with her unless that dude is
there and if this guy's really your
[ __ ] friend by the way
wait a minute this guy's really your
friend you know you wouldn't be thinking
about doing that and be oh man I don't
know if you tell him I don't know if you
should tell I wouldn't tell him it's
it's a [ __ ] mess you know a woman
would women would women would initiate
the conversation and then turn around
and [ __ ] - you don't yeah don't tell
them don't tell them that's a stupid
[ __ ] idea cuz then she'll flip the
[ __ ] story start crying he'll feel
bad and he's gonna choose her over you
there you got a situation that's just so
many [ __ ] ways that this can go and
none of its good unless you just walk
away walk away go back to the room go
back to the room [ __ ] it it's that
moment and [ __ ] when you're playing
cards we just gotta admit you're not
gonna win tonight just [ __ ] cash out
and go back to the [ __ ] room that's
what you should do
jerk off to her as much as you [ __ ]
want to get it out of your system go
find somebody else that you like that
makes you not think about your buddy's
wife how about that there there we go
but I'm sure she just wants to feel free
all right I know I was a little bit of
an [ __ ] but what are you gonna do
alright that's the podcast once again
thank you everybody came out in
Vancouver and I'm going to be in Ontario
coming up this weekend on the 17th
whatever the [ __ ] I'm gonna be I came it
begins with an L I think it's up on my
website bill at billboard.com that's the
podcast go [ __ ] yourselves and I'll
check in on you on Thursday